let's bring in chip kelly who joins us
the ucla head coach it's 7 30 your time
is it too early for a bratwurst for you
we do not have the girls fired up at the
moment but i can make a suggestion
so yeah i think it sounds pretty good
lynch that sound
when's the last time you tailgated oh
god
um i
don't know you've never like gone
through the parking lot
at the rose bowl and then decided to
just stop off and
maybe grab a dog or say hello to uh some
boosters
there were some games i probably should
have
let me just stay here i don't know 16
minutes are going to be what i want it
to be so
how do you explain what has happened
here in the last two months
six weeks i don't know i mean it this is
crazy
it it is it's well the best thing is
when you say it's 2020.
so anything is expected
you know i i think um we all thought on
august 11th that we weren't going to
play
um you know there were some of our
schools obviously that and it's
different because it's different here
that's the one thing about covet is that
it's different in different parts of the
country so when you look at
there are other people playing well it's
not that bad in their state and then
there's other states where
you know we were not allowed in our
building until the beginning of this
week so we have not been in
this building that i'm in right now you
know our players had not been in a
weight room since march until monday
so it's different so when people say how
come they're not playing well there's
different restrictions
um at the state level in the local level
that prevented us from preparing our
guys to play so we understood when the
decision was passed down
in august because of the restrictions
that a lot of us were on so
you know i i think the rapid testing on
a daily basis is
is the key and that's what we hope will
be able to get us to to play on november
7th
can is six weeks enough time to get
ready
yeah it's pushing it you know when i
hear people say how come how does it
take six weeks well because our players
hadn't been really doing anything
you know if our players in a normal year
are with our strength coach during all
of june and all of july then you need
four weeks of camp and you can go
because
they've had eight weeks to get ready for
camp you know there are some schools us
specifically the california schools that
haven't had the opportunity to do that
so
we think six weeks will prepare us for
it
um but but as you watch other leagues
and that's what we've done watch other
leagues
you're concerned you know and the
concern is you look at all the injuries
that have happened in the national
football league and they had six weeks
to ramp up and
and the the injuries that are an
all-time rate and and they kind of rival
when
the strike season happened in 2011 you
know so there's a correlation there
between
how much time you have to prepare and
we're very cognizant of that that's why
i think they gave us six weeks and we
just have to be really smart with these
six weeks that we have coming up here
yeah i looked at what was happening in
the nfl and i gave my audience
a heads up i said you're going to see
soft tissue injuries because
you didn't get that opportunity you
can't simulate you know a game
no matter how much you try you can't and
so
i mean that how much of a concern is
that going to be for you
uh with with your players i think it's a
concern for all the coaches
in in our situation and you talk to the
coaches in the big
ten that are are two weeks ahead of us
you know it's the same concern with all
of us
um if a player tests positive for covet
he's out for whatever the time he has to
quarantine if he's asymptomatic is it 14
days or 21 days depending on what your
league is but if a guy pulls a hamstring
he could be out for 21 days also
so and when you're playing a six game or
seven game regular season if you're
missing three weeks with a hamstring
injury
it's like missing a season so we have to
be really smart in how we prepare our
guys
you i don't know if it's better than
spring football
because you didn't get that opportunity
for spring football and last time we
talked
we didn't think we were having fall
football but would you rather have
this truncated six seven game schedule
or
roll the dice and try to play in the
spring
as long as it's safe and i think what
the the key is
is the fact that we have daily testing
so if you tell me it's a safe
environment and that every day we go to
work out here
um the guys we're working out against
we're positive that no one is
is uh is carrying covert then then then
we want to play and we want to compete
and our players are excited about that
but
they have the same concerns is it going
to be a safe environment and from what
we understand with the new testing
and um they're starting to implement
that or hopefully by next week
that it will be and if it's a safe
environment our guys won't play football
they want to compete and
we all want to do that you know spring
ball's fun from a teaching standpoint
but
you know whoever wins the spring game
you know for who gets burgers and who
gets hot dogs is uh or now bratwurst we
could have problems
um is it really like playing against sc
you know and then you look at not
you know you're getting started later
and
can a team get into the final four
conversation uh
with the pac-12 yeah and and you're
probably going to
you know get x'ed out you're not you're
not going to have enough games in the
time frame as well and
i don't know if you have a great team in
the pac-12 this year
you're right on all points and i i don't
know how it
fits um i think at least there'll be a
conversation
um but you don't know and there's so
many unknowns you know
the fact that you're getting all these
congratulation phone calls on hey you
guys are going to get to play i'm like
well we hope so and
what do you mean by that i said there's
already been 21 games canceled
so you know we could get to the
beginning of our season and then have
games because of covin in an outbreak at
a on a campus or at a school
and have some of our seven games
canceled so we have a seven game season
scheduled but that doesn't mean we're
going to get them all in and and you
know you look at houston who's had five
they've had five games canceled you know
that i don't know
how we would head to that you know if we
start we're playing a seven game season
and you get five of them canceled so
um i don't know and i i heard them say
yesterday
the one thing that they came out with
was that there's no
um threshold for games one to be bow
eligible so
um i'd like to congratulate everybody in
the background on being bowl elephant
are we are we having regular bowl games
i
i think they are but i don't know i i
don't think you can use the word regular
at all
in 2020 okay but what does that mean you
may fly somewhere
and play a game real quick but then is
the opponent playing
with the same testing protocols that you
have and there's a lot more that goes
into a selection
uh that selection sunday will be very
interesting like we have to match up
people that have the same testing
protocols
so let's put this team against that team
well neither of the teams won a game
don't worry about it
you don't know you know i hope that our
testing protocol puts us at the top of
the list for bowl selection so
well maybe you'll face a big ten team
that they would have the same testing
i think they got the same testing so
that'd be great uh we're talking to chip
kelly ucla head coach
what do you remember about gardner
minshew at washington state
um we didn't play against him
because we that we did we missed him in
the rotation so i just watched him on
film
okay and was so thoroughly impressed you
know just with
his competitiveness uh his decision
making how quick he was
and how decisive he was in making
decisions um
and it's you know part of what mike does
with his quarterbacks but
you know he he may have been one of the
better ones to ever play in that system
for him and and
you're seeing him do it in the nfl you
know it's
uh you know last night wasn't a great
night for him but i know what he's done
up until this point in time has just
been kind of extraordinary honestly
best quarterback you ever faced
where you just didn't have an answer
uh in the nfl was aaron rodgers
you know he he just there were times i
think he was just
smiling like this coverage all thrown
here are you gonna play this coverage
i'll throw it here
all right this one i'm gonna keep the
play alive for a little bit and then i'm
gonna throw it it kind of looks like i'm
going right but i'm gonna throw it left
so
and i know aaron and it was just it was
a it was a long day
um at the college level and i still
maintain though coach
aaron rodgers makes when he's great
he makes it look easier than any other
quarterback i've ever seen
and and that's that's bringing in a lot
of quarterbacks
rogers and i i understand that feeling
of what you must have
because he just at times he feels like
he's he's playing
chess and you're playing checkers with
him i agree
and and in the same note i would put
russell wilson in that same category
because russell can just beat you with
his legs and it's russell's like oh
you're gonna be in coverage i'll take
off and run for 20.
and then you never can hit him because
russell will never take a hit because
he's so smart
and then he also just sticks the ball
out for an extra yard just to add insult
to injury every single time he goes out
of bounds and
and he's got the same they both have the
same um passion for playing so they're
they're always up they're always
positive it's it's they were difficult
at the college level for us it was
probably cam you know when we played him
in the national championship because
it you know it was like the first time
you ever see cam in person
you know he looks like charles oakley
and he's playing quarterback and you're
like oh my god
like this is the quarterback you know
he's bigger than anybody we have on our
defensive line so
um and then the combination of how well
the thing that impressed me the first
time i saw cam is how well he threw the
ball you would think all right
this is brandon jacobs back there and
they're just gonna run quarterback power
all the time but
he can really spend he's one of the best
we played him in the nfl also he's one
of the best deep ball throwers i've seen
so
um you know bill's got a the the
patriots are the real deal with canada
quarterback but did you
face uh brady yes
and did you didn't have you didn't come
away with that same impression that you
had with aaron rodgers
no let's not get into that
would you rather say something negative
about usc right now
we're just hopeful we could get on the
field to play again we're all we're all
in a happy place right now
but tom was i mean tom's phenomenal too
it's there's
there's so many when they're playing at
that higher level we played peyton
and that was just a clinic and you know
it's when you get to see those elite
guys play the the tom brady's and the
russell wilson's and
cam and tom it's it's hard to be but
when paige that's why everybody says if
you have a quarterback you got a shot
when peyton goes to the line of
scrimmage and you know
on the sidelines that he knows what
you're doing like
how how intimidating or frustrating is
that
it's we played them in denver my first
year
and it was second down
in the first down and it was so close to
the red zone
and you could tell as he caught the snap
he didn't like the route the receiver
was running
so he immediately threw it in the ground
like he was spiking the ball
and then he said something to the
receiver ran back to the line of
scrimmage in a hurry up mode
and threw a touchdown pass on us and i
was just like
anybody else would have tried that well
the receiver in the wrong route i'm
going to extend this play
and you know try to see if i can make
something out of it he was like
wrong throws it in the ground gets up
next play touchdown and i was like
wow i've never seen that before but he
knew exactly what he wanted and he got
the look he wanted and he knew he was
going to score that
that's very difficult to defend what
about the defensive player uh
peyton would talk about how zach thomas
like
there's certain defensive players they
would just whenever he called out
something he would go
uh you know look for the draw look for
the you know and he he said he was one
of the smartest players that he he went
against
is there a defensive player that's the
equivalent of peyton or some of these
other quarterbacks
when when when i was there it was luke
lee i mean he could diagnose
everything and anything and you know
there were checks you put in that game
and he was calling out
i was like that's the first time we've
used that checklist how does he know
that like
but he was just such an instinctive
linebacker you know you try to do some
things
in terms of how you hand it off and make
it look like a counter move but you run
an inside zone and
you fool him once you call it one you
call it another time 35 plays later and
you didn't fool him and he's in the
backfield for two yard loss
and the same kind of look that aaron
would give you smiling like hey you got
me once but you're never going to get me
twice but
kiki would kickly was like that it's
great to talk to you you got a smile on
your face
hopefully we got football coming up here
we got our fingers crossed
so we we hope that on november 7th we
could have a bratwurst
well hopefully it's a victory bratwurst
yes thank you coach
great to talk to you guys that's uh chip
kelly ucla head coach